[Musik]
naja leute will kommt neuem video erhält
jedes gut aus sieht man mich überhaupt
ja heute was geht ich hoffe natürlich
euch jetzt gut herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen es entlocken ich muss
erstmal sagen die letzten tage waren
wirklich sehr anstrengend gamescom party
noch eine party und ich hab's augen
sehen oder das lieblingsessen sind
trinken
ich bin auch wirklich noch fertig
trotzdem machen wir jetzt mit video und
so hatte ich letztes mal gefragt jo
schreib doch mal in die kommentare was
sie in zukunft noch haben wollt für
videos mit essen und einen kommentare
hatte doch einfach mal das größte
restaurant in köln und ich habe mir
gedacht okay am anfang fand ich den
kommentar nicht so geil aber das waren
wir heute also eigentlich ist doch cool
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich gehe sehr oft
essen und habe auch so in köln viele
stamm lokale sag ich mal wo ich dass er
ein bei anderen wahlen
was ist ein restaurant
aber das ist halt so ein ganz normales
und nichts das jetzt irgendwie keine
ahnung 50 euro kostet oder so 19 12
natürlich war ich auch schon mal steak
essen für 25 euro oder so aber noch
nichts wo man uns gesagt hat okay das
hat jetzt wirklich extrem viel geld
gekostet also gehobene küche nennt sich
das ja ich habe schon mal ziemlich viel
geguckt teuerstes restaurant in köln
gourmetrestaurants in köln die zehn
besten restaurants in köln das problem
ist bei der ersten quelle das ist halt
irgendwie schon geschlossen und gourmet
restaurant in köln fine dining schick
essen gehen in kölns guten restaurants
und zwar verbirgt sich dahinter ein
restaurant regionales und mediterranes
gehobene küche
das ist ich habe gerade seine
speisekarte gelesen da steht einfach
herz leber und niere vom eifeler
das ist glücklich wir gehen jetzt immer
auf die speisekarten von dem von dem
ding was gibt's da so eine kalte suppe
salat
ich glaube ich noch unser und
vegetarisch risotto rotbarsch wie le
maire fisch steht kalbszunge in
schnittlauch soßen braten mit blutwurst
karamellisierte äpfel und zwiebeln
aufgeklappte gibt es ja auch entenleber
die habe ich eher woanders gesehen gibt
es aber irgendwie so keine ahnung was
das sein soll
pizza mit eis dran danach weil du wirst
du bestimmt was mit erdbeer oder so
sondern eben ist doch ein eis oder ja
und das ist aber naja also wir fahren
jetzt einfach mal hin
mal gucken wie teuer ist im endeffekt
wird und natürlich muss das jetzt nicht
heißen das ist wirklich das teuerste
restaurant ganz köln es gibt bestimmt
noch irgendwo einsatz teurer ist aber
ich habe ja schön aber ich habe jetzt
das halt gefunden und da fahren wir hin
wollte ich nur kurz klarstellen das
heißt wenn ihr jetzt irgendwie ein scan
was noch teurer ist sagt jan den
kommentaren aber für mich war das jetzt
das heißt also und was aber auch noch
ganz wichtig ist ich sehe gerade aus
wieso ich habe in meinem schrank zwar
auch so keine ahnung acht normale hosen
aber das meiste ist eigentlich
jogginghose und deswegen ziehe ich mich
jetzt erst mal um so auf change in 32
derweil sind dann auch der angerufen um
einen tisch bestellt um sicher zu gehen
dass wir deswegen natürlich kann ich
stelle mir da camera film sondern so
heimlich mit handy versuche ich nur das
sehr viel schneller als du wir sind
glaube ich ein bisschen früh dran
auf jeden fall hat die kamera leider
nicht mehr viele grüne noch zehn prozent
und ich will jetzt natürlich auch nicht
den namen von diesen dingen sagen weil
keine ahnung weiß ja nie ob wieder so
gut finde ich sehe das so gut es geht
deswegen wundert euch nicht aber ich hab
hunger und ich hatte mal den spalten die
speisekarte gecheckt und mit mehr spaß
das stand da wahrscheinlich gar nicht
nur dass es meistens so glaube ich an so
teuren sachen wenn du irgendwo richtig
so wirklich richtig krass teuer essen
gehst da steht doch kein preis dran
naja wir sehen uns gleich wenn wir da
sind ich bin auf jeden fall gespannt so
wir sind jetzt fast zum wirken parkplatz
gefunden
also das wird schon aufs handy und sehen
uns in der stunde aber so wie man gucken
ob es lecker wird vor allem weil wir
genau jetzt in die kommentare was tippt
ihr ich sage für uns beide zusammen weil
du jetzt nicht so viel essen 50 60 euro
oder so ich versuche das jetzt mal ein
bisschen nach zu dokumentieren also hier
gehen wir hin ja zwar wir schon drin
ich habe mich hingesetzt wir waren die
einzigen am anfang und da waren einfach
alles voll mit kellnern wir uns nun bis
hinten angeguckt haben ich habe auch
immer so einen leichten stirnglatze
reingelegt ja dann habe ich mir meinen
ersten ausgesucht dann haben wir
vorspeisen gekriegt
kaum ein steakmesser gerade und da war
das essen auch schon da ich hatte so ein
trikot hier sieht man ein bild davon und
marie hatte irgendwie so ein ravioli in
champignons mit irgendeiner füllung
manchmal wirklich sehr lecker dazu
hatten wir noch so zwei salate
die waren aber dabei die so soll auch
richtig litt ja und ich hab halt immer
versucht möglichst gut zu füllen
es gibt es von nachtisch genau da war
ich auf dem klo wieder zurück nachspeise
gab es noch die war auch ganz cool
[Gelächter]
das wirtschafts gleich wieder auf die
andere kämen preislich hätte eigentlich
so gedacht das wird teuer aber es war
trotzdem fiel also sehr viel sonst würde
ich niemals so viel für ärzte bezahlen
erst mal ab ins warme autos irgendwie
kalt geworden so leute wir sind auf
jeden fall wieder zurück im auto auf
einer skala von 1-10 wie lecker was für
dich
3 ich hoffe ich komme aus dieser scheiß
parklücke aus ja auf jeden fall was ich
noch sagen wollte dass jetzt aus der
parklücke rausgekommen
wir sind halt rein gekommen und wir
waren die einzigen tag und da waren fünf
kellner da waren fünf kellner und haben
wir auch schon darüber geredet ich sag
mal so natürlich sind solche restaurants
cool aber ich fühle mich da halt total
unwohl ist halt nicht so meine welt ich
glaube dafür bin ich noch zu jung oder
auf jeden fall kann ich euch noch einmal
die quittung zeigen wir haben jetzt für
ich etwas normales gäste also sowas ist
ich habe mir ravioli es als mangold man
am bio ließ mit pilzen drin
und
und wir haben für alles insgesamt werden
beide eine cola und haben uns doch
nachricht geholt glaube ich jetzt 57
euro bezahlt also ich habe 750 euro
gebraucht das zu sagen was dein essen
hälfte des geldes eingenommen hat das
ding ist das ist jetzt ein betrag der
eigentlich gar nicht mal so krass hoch
ist es gibt natürlich restaurants die
noch teurer sind wobei ich habe noch nie
in meinem leben bis jetzt in dem
restaurant mehr als 40 euro oder so
höchstens für zwei personen bezahlt
eigentlich allerhöchstens noch mal 30
weil du zahlst du mir als 15 euro pro
person finde ich und 57 war schon extrem
teuer
ach nee stimmt wo wir das erste mal
essen da habe ich aber nicht 750 bezahlt
habe ich höchstens 50 bezahlt also das
war schon wirklich teuer
wobei man halt auch dazu sagen musst du
macht es ja wirklich nicht mal ein
richtiges gericht ja ja alles leben 80
euro für zwei personen
da muss man schon mal schlucken aber das
erste mal wirklich richtig richtig gut
also musste ich unbedingt noch mal dahin
gehen aber das wird sich auf jeden fall
gelohnt
achso hier noch die rechnung
wir haben hier ein 50 euro 90 zwei
gerichte und dann gibt's ja aber
ungefähr 10% trinkl was mir jetzt noch
durch einige recherchen aufgefallen weil
ich halt wirklich gedacht habt okay das
war jetzt war ein tolles restaurant
keine frage und es gibt auch sicherlich
in köln auch restaurants die teurer sind
leider war es jetzt halt so dass wir das
im internet gefunden haben das weiß kein
sterne restaurant wo man dann halt
verschiedene gänge hatte die insgesamt
über 100 euro gekostet haben
aber es war wirklich ja eines der
teureren restaurants in köln weiß ich
bin noch am überlegen ob ich einen titel
schreibe das teuerste restaurant und
köln oder eines der teuersten macht ihr
nämlich übel was mir auffällt wenn wir
zu zweit in einem wirklich richtige und
steak aus gewesen wären
wären wir sogar drüber gewesen weil ich
habe schon mal alleine in einem
steakhouse 35 euro bezahlen und steak
und getränke denkt sie auch so was hält
die komische leute ihr könnt ja gerne
auch weitere essens aufgaben in die
kommentare schreiben
sonst würde ich auch mal beim
günstigsten genau das können wir auch
machen schreibt auf jeden fall richtig
gute schreibt auf jeden fall mal in die
kommentare
das günstigste restaurant in köln ob wir
da irgendwas ist nämlich lässt die
kommentare durch wenn wir das von uns
war unter die lupe genommen ich hoffe
ich konnte das auch gut dokumentieren
mit meiner handykamera ich wollte so ein
bisschen versteckt film halt ich habe
die ganze gar nicht gecheckt nicht
vergessen auf jeden fall
und wie schon gesagt weitere erstens
aufgaben in die kommentare